The Joe Rogan experience.
He's the re I've told this story before, but I'll tell it to you.
He's the reason why this table is this wide. Oh, you were just nervous.
This table was going to be sh I was going to make it more narrow.
I even had a smaller table that we were working with as a guide.
Then we're still doing the shows back in LA, more setting up this studio.
I did an interview with Tyson and he was so amped up for this Roy Jones fight
that I got nervous. I'm like, I like that extra six inches.
That's hilarious space between us because he was so ramped up. Oh man.
When he left, Jamie goes, that's a totally different person. Yeah,
because he went from being Mike Tyson, pot grower,
not working out at all to get ready to go to combat again,
getting ready to throw hands. Yeah. Yeah. That's so amped up.
And we've all watched the video where he calls that photographer out and he's
like, I'll, you beat your. You pitch on make you love me. Yeah. I watched that.
I'm like, ah, I said, I'll you until you love me. Wow.
Where does that come from? That's demon. That's letting the dude. No,
he's going to be him for a long time. Yeah. But it's a weird jump.
Cause he's not actually going to the guy. Who's going to beat the out of him.
He might, he might. If he decides to that's his call,
that's what it, that's what it is. Yeah. That's what it is.
Dominating that at you. He's letting you know if I decide to yeah.
I'll you until you love me. That is like one of the deepest,
darkest things a person's ever said to somebody that haunts me at night.
Terrifying. But us back then, I mean,
he was in his prime. Oh yeah. It was. That was, you know,
post-prison I think that was the Lennox Lewis fight.
I believe that was the press conference for the Lennox Lewis fight.
So then wasn't exactly prime, but we didn't know that yet.
He was kind of still in the area of like, you'd already lost a Buster Douglas,
right? He might've already lost two Evander Holyfield. I think he did it.
I don't know. Just amazing to this people on this planet who are like, Oh,
I'll fight that guy. They're looking at video footage of this killer.
And they're like, yeah, I'll take them. There's a lot of killers out there.
And they always want to be the man who beats the man. That's what it is.
That gives me hope.
I know we call it toxic masculinity or whatever the hell evil men.
But it it's amazing that somebody would want to go toe to toe with this,
what is this about? This is a different, I know it is. I'll eat your children.
Oh, this is a different one. Play this, play this.
Plane.
Uh, JMO. Jamie, the COVID has really hurt yet. It's I've been slacking since.
Yeah. I don't know something's wrong by the way. Quite a hog on Jaymo.
I saw it in the sweat pants. Yeah. Quite a piece you got there. There you go,
man. He's not denying it either. He's smiling. He's all red. Now look,
Oh my God. You look like the walls. No, get it up there. Get it up.
Tell them that they come up with a, with a hog employee.
Legitimate, legitimate, like good to go.
Universally accepted the way fake boobs are accepted. Yeah,
because fake boobs are basically normal. No one says, listen,
you got a great personality, but this is. Girls in high school are doing that.
Oh yeah. Oh yeah. Oh yeah. How was that? Well, you know, you hit 18 or whatever.
Oh God. But yeah. I feel like it should be 21 before you do something like that.
Yeah. But man, when I killed her a huge Dawn, how big would you want? Well,
your, your, your there's rumors about your, uh, your and balls there. But uh,
I used to have a bit about big Dick pills. Yeah. There was big Dick pills.
It would take about 30 seconds for the first guy diving overdose. No,
one's going to take just one. If a pill makes your Dick bigger,
we'd be thinking like, how many do I take before I get a stroke?
Give me one less. Right. And let's do this. I'm like,
it would change the shape of vaginas because there would be no regular Dixon
anymore. Within here we go. Here we go.
With Mike Tyson. Who's standing by with Jim gray, Jim. Yeah. Okay. Thank you,
Steve. Mike was that your shortest fight ever. I've been winning.
If there's only one God and Muhammad blessings and peace.
Be upon him as a prophet. I dedicate this vital. My brother,
Darryl bond who died. I'll be there to see you. I love you with all my heart.
All praise. Be to my children. I love you. Oh God, our man.
What is this? Your shortest fight.
Anytime. Amateur professional. I'm great. Hanging in there. Yeah.
Um, I don't know, man. Yeah. Yeah.
Lennox Lewis Linux. I'm coming for you.
Like is it frustrating to train like you did and then have this as seven or
eight seconds.
But if I only trained probably two weeks or three weeks for this fight,
I had to bury my best friend and I dedicated this fight.
I wasn't going to fight. I dedicated this. Fight them.
I was going to rip his heart out. I'm the best ever.
I'm the most brutal and Michigan most ruthless champion has ever been there's no
one could stop me legs to the conquer. No, I'm Alexander. He's no Alexander.
I'm the best ever. They've never been anybody lifted. I'm Jack Dempsey.
There's no one like me. I'm from their cloth. There's no one that can match me.
My style is impetuous. My defense is impregnable and I'm just from brochures.
I want your heart. I want to eat your children. Praise be to our law.
Whoa.
The craziest post-fight speech of all time is
no second place. No, he's got great writers. Holy come on.
And even the waves, my style's impetuous, my defense is impregnable. Yeah.
It was just bam. I am Sonny Liston. I'm Jack Dempsey. I'm from their cloth.
Woo. He got to there from the easiest question. That was a yes or no quiz.
Is this the shortest fight only to say what?
And he just went all the way to left field. That was amazing. Yeah.
That was heavy. That was heavy. I would, I mean, could you be in his entourage?
Because he seems like a guy who just flip on a dime and you just like, Hey,
you want the Funyuns? I kill ya. You're like, Oh, I'm sorry.
We've been best friends for 30 years. I don't know if he would be like that. Uh,
when I've met him, he's been very nice, very friendly to everybody.
But I think when you're a dude,
that's that driven and that maniacal when you're at your best,
I mean, he was, you got to realize like throughout his life,
all of his great success came from his ability to be
ferocious. All of it. Right?
I mean the whole success of his fighting career came from his skill,
his technique and his ability in the heat of the moment to be ferocious.
She was just geared up for that. I know there it is. Right. This is,
this is the other one though. The brawl. Yeah.
Oh God, that guy must have been true.
[Inaudible].
Heavy. I mean, how do you go back to the green room with that guy? You uh,
you go, uh you're right Mike? Yeah. Good point. Well said,
well said, I think you did everything. Perfect. Let's get out of here.
As I was that week as white boy, I would have been running out the fire exit.
That guy is still to this day. Probably if he's still alive,
probably wakes up in the middle of the night,
thinking of Mike Tyson over his bed. Oh, I love you.
I love you punching him in the face. Holy. But again like the,
in the context of a regular life,
that is a outrageous behavior that you would never expect from anybody,
but in the context of a life where you're rewarded for being the most
ferocious and your ruthlessly successful
at doing that, like that is normal. This is like you, like,
you look at his fights, the stoppage of Trevor Berbick to win the title.
You look at his destruction of Tyrell, Biggs and Marvis Frazier.
And you go through his career and of course he's got that in him.
That's how he can turn it on. But that feels like more, there's more there.
That's why he's one of the greatest ever lace up the gloves.
But it seems like there was some real trauma,
like we don't know about a hundred percent. Yeah.
We'll tell he talked about that trauma,
but that trauma is also what motivated me to be so great. Right.
See the thing about a guy like him, it's like you,
you can't get there any other way. He was not,
it wasn't that it was just skillful and just competitive and just
unbelievably,
technically proficient in the art of smashing people with your fists. Yeah.
He also had an extra gear that other people didn't have. He was, you know,
and he was even hypnotized when he was a young boy. Really? Yeah. Custom motto.
Uh,
he was telling me the whole story of it on the podcast that custom motto took
him when he was a young boy, you got to realize he's like 13 years old.
He gets adopted by one of the greatest minds in the history of boxing. Right?
Custom motto was a, he was a, he was, he,
he really understood psychology like deeply.
And he was one of the great boxing trainers trade. He trained Floyd Patterson,
Jose Torres, like world champions. He's in the game forever.
And he was always looking for that one great fighter.
And he found it in his 13 year old kid. And he knew right away.
Cause his 13 year old kid was 190 pounds, 13,
190 jacked at 13 credits just had incredible natural
ability and drive was getting praised for doing something finally,
whereas all of his life,
right on and dismissed and locked in jail and all this different stuff. Now,
all of a sudden he's getting praised for it. And then he's getting hypnotized.
It's getting hypnotized by this guy was telling him you don't exist.
Only the task exists.
Don't fill your mind with thoughts of yourself and good or bad,
or I'm a bad person. I'm a good brother. You don't exist. You just,
you are the task and you move forward and you attack Jesus.
When he was saying that you don't exist.
Like thinking that just the task exists.
So he's got him so focused on going out there and attacking that
person while the other person has all these doubts and fears and this and that
in their mind. But he's trained to think like a local motion just to train
coming at you. You're not going to stop him.
He's just gonna figure out he's not, he's not filled with self doubt.
He's filled with confidence. He's filled with knowing at the end of him,
smashing you in the face, you're going to be lying on your back.
And he's going to get that amazing,
good feeling that he gets every time he does this. Right?
So every time he smashes people, he gets this incredible feeling.
So he's dedicated,
just like we were talking about lazy comics that lazy comics can become like
actually discipline when they want to get their act together to do stand up.
A fighter is so motivated by that great feeling of winning,
of winning that you just become, the more you feel it, the more you want it.
And the more discipline you get and the more you drive towards it.
And that was him. Plus then yeah,
that guy with all that hypnotic and then fame and then money. I mean,
that's a bad gumbo. It's about gumbo and look, look what happened.
Why he's okay now? Well, on the other side, uh,
an interesting person did that's true. Particularly,
particularly before the fight. Um, you know,
like before he signed on to the fight,
the first time I met him and talked to him, I met him before the UFC.
But the first time I talked to him on the podcast, he was an interesting guy.
He's like a, a very thoughtful person. He thinks a lot about things,
but daddy's got that switch.
And he turned that switch on before the Roy Jones fight.
Or you can tell which I think he won. Yeah. If it was a decision. Yeah,
for sure. But there was no decisions.
I was trying to see if anybody knew who Mike was yelling at the crowd there. Oh.
So I Googled it and look who was in the crowd. Oh,
live. He was doing it for the tonight show with Jay Leno. He's like a whole
JMR, like talking to tons of people, skinny Davis gig, uh, young,
young days. You got to bring this up. When you see him tonight.
This is amazing Lennox.
I don't think there's a part where he's talking to Mike here at least,
but probably for safety. He may or may not have been the guy yell on that. No,
no, he's a white boy. Oh, okay. That's okay. Okay. Okay.
Dave would never yell out of snow. No, no, no. I know there's jokes online.
He was yelling to Jim brewer. That's amazing. That's amazing.
It's a lot of people are listening. They're like who you're talking about. Oh,
right, right. A skinny, young, very young Dave Chappelle and they're playing
Jack Lennox. Lewis rock. Remember you were a young comic.
You'd take these weird gigs.
That is hilarious. Wow. You forget the body of work.
People have just done so much in showbiz.
Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free. Only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.